there's a vast and global scandal behind
the journey from plow to plate
internationally over 800 million people
into your hunger yet the world wastes at
least a third of all the food it
produces even in the wealthiest nations
millions suffer from food poverty one in
four Americans say they struggle to
afford food its deprivation in a sea of
Plenty over 30 percent of America's food
or 160 billion dollars worth gets wasted
just by grocery stores and their
customers that is more than enough to
feed all the world's malnourished people
growing food demands land water fossil
fuels and soil and its production is the
single biggest impact we humans have had
on nature the foundation of our food
system is our farms the tragedy is that
some farmers can't sell half of what
they've grown due to cosmetic standards
dictated by supermarkets it's a brutal
casting session where crooked Kenyan
beans and blemished British carrots are
all discarded with blinkered eyes we
fail to see the beauty in these ugly veg
and supermarkets regularly cancel or
change orders at the last minute meaning
that food already produced by their
suppliers gets dumped farmers bear the
cost of this waste though it's not their
fault
supermarkets purposefully create an
image of overflowing abundance a
hard-wired human response to glut is to
buy in excess this is the marketing
strategy that results in us buying more
than we need and creating mountains of
wasted food meanwhile Oh
cautious date labels confuse and
frighten customers so they toss out
what's still good to eat
cafes buffets and restaurants are all
complicit in the allure of excess
overproducing to maintain a full menu
round-the-clock and they serve customers
ever larger portion sizes that are paid
for but often left uneaten from 1982 to
2002 the average pizza slice grooves 70%
in calories and the average
chocolate-chip cookie quadrupled we
super-sized our problems along with the
food as these extra calories use up
scarce land water and fossil fuels food
donations from retailers and restaurants
are proven ways of redistributing some
of this nutritious surplus while it's
still fit for consumption but many
businesses still reason that it's
cheaper and easier to fill their
dumpsters instead and if you include the
food that humans could eat but instead
use to fatten livestock for more dairy
and meat you find that a country like
America has indirect access to four
times as many calories as it needs
instead of tossing this food
supermarkets manufacturers and caterers
must be pushed to direct it to charities
that feed hungry people government's
should intervene when powerful retailers
cancel orders and dump their food waste
on farmers refusing to pay the bill and
even if it's not fit for human
consumption it can at least be fed to
livestock especially pigs and chickens
regulations preventing this need to be
changed
we should purchase what we need and eat
what we purchase and demand that the
powerful companies controlling much of
the food system measure and take
responsibility for the waste they caused
governments should use the vast
subsidies they offer to incentivize
farmers to look after the land in ways
that protect the planet rather than
turning out more food to fill our
dumpsters and over fill our bellies and
we all need to recognize that food is
too precious to waste
I'm Sarah Nolan I'm 24 years old and I
serve as an AmeriCorps fellow at Habitat
for Humanity